In the last video we covered the history
of Germany from its earliest beginnings
up through the late Middle Ages.
Is that video got a magnificent response.
Thank you.
While greatly for that and this video,
we are going to conclude that history
as we pick up where we left off and
continue to modern day Germany budget.
Before we begin,
I'd like to thank Laura and
Ashley A, B, c, d, e, f, g,
and Gabby are for being our
most recent patrion supporters.
And now without further ado,
last owns sliding start.
We left off around the year 1437 what's
the death of Emperor Sigismund who was
succeeded by Albert the second
and then Friedrich the third,
both of the house of Habsburg.
The Teutonic order had been successfully
challenged by Poland and Lithuania at
the battle of groove vault
a few decades earlier,
and the situation in the Baltic
region was now more precarious.
The Muslim Ottoman Turks were advancing
closer to imperial territory in 1453
they would take the city of Constantinople
destroying the Byzantine Empire,
which sparked fear
throughout the German lands.
The Hoh Hanzo learns had become the
margarines of Brandenburg centering their
power in an emerging city,
Berlin,
despite political divisions as a time,
Germany was an economic powerhouse.
It is also some time in the 15th century
that the country takes on the new name
of the holy Roman empire
of the German nation.
The 15th and 16th century in Germany was
a period of earth shaking change as it
was now entering the renaissance,
a period of technological,
philosophical and religious
changes and advances,
which marks the end of the medieval era.
One such innovation which took place in
the city of mines in 14 and 39 was the
invention of the printing press by
Yohanis Gutenberg, which changed forever,
how the written word and therefore ideas
and knowledge was spread across Europe.
In 1493 maximum million.
The first became emperor with
personal domains growing.
Many of the emperors of the age preferred
to live outside the political mess
that was the center of the
Holy Roman Empire at the time,
living and dying and Austria,
Bohemia and Hungary.
The lack of the presence of the emperor.
Only worse than the divides in Germany.
At the time,
leaving the nobility within the country
without a center around which to meet
often resulting in fuse and armed
conflicts between them with no clear
arbitrators along with politics,
other areas of life such as religion.
We're becoming areas
of contention as well.
Soon perhaps Christianity's biggest
divide would begin in Germany,
sparked by a monk named Martin Luther
Martine Aloo tear was born November 10th,
1483 in central Germany,
originally pressured by his father to
become a lawyer in 1505 while causing a
fierce storm.
Luther is said to have promised God at
that he would become a monk if he were
spared. The exact events are not known,
but Luther kept true to his promise.
Luther was an especially pious and
devoted monk fulfilling his duties
vigorously. However, he was not
merely a simple, dutiful monk.
He viewed things in the big picture
and searched deeply for meaning within
religion and is spiritually
challenging time. As time went on,
he began to question certain
practices of the Catholic Church,
partly inspired by past
reformers such as yon whois.
One issue of which Luther was skeptical
was the Catholic churches selling of
indulgences.
Purchasing an indulgence was simply a
way for an individual to reduce their or
someone else's time and purgatory.
Luther saw this as a corrupt scheme and
noticed that that key figures involved
had financial burdens.
Pope Leo the 10th for example,
sought funding to rebuild
St Peter's basilica in Rome.
Luther began to question the selling
of indulgences and as time went on,
even dare to directly
challenged the church on the
issue using it as an entrance
to challenge it on other issues as well.
The tail of Luther's next move is
one of history's most famous moments.
On October 31st,
1517 Luther nailed his disputation
on the power of indulgences,
better known as his 95 theses to the
door of the church in Wittenberg where he
challenged the power of the Catholic
Church and boldly began what is remembered
as the Protestant reformation history
has perhaps somewhat romanticize this
scene.
It is uncertain whether Luther actually
nailed the 95 theses to the church door.
Furthermore, it would be somewhat
incorrect at this point of view.
Luther as a renegade.
His intention was not yet to leave
the Catholic church only to reform it.
The 95 theses were meant to
be starting points for debate,
not necessarily a list of demands.
They were written in Latin
and only translated into
German by other people later
on implying Luther had no desire
yet for popular revolution.
Luther would also question more deeply
held aspects of Catholicism as well.
Eventually becoming more radical and
questioning the necessity of the Catholic
church itself. Much of his life was then
spent in bitter dispute with the church.
By 1521 he was summoned to the
Diet of worms by now Maximillian.
The first had been
succeeded by his grandson,
crawled at fifth who was also King of
Spain and Ruler of Lens and Burgundy and
Italy and via Spain,
the Americas.
He would be the first European ruler to
claim to have an empire upon which the
sun never set.
Though he did not yet speak German.
He resided over the Diet where
Luther was expected to recant.
Luther did not recant in the
face of the most powerful forces.
The day he stood by his works and what
he believed to be the truth saying,
unless I am convinced by the testimony
of descriptors or by clear reason for I
do not trust and either the
pope or the councils alone,
since it is well known that they have
often erred and contradicted themselves,
I am bound by the scriptures I have
quoted at my conscience is captive to the
word of God.
I can not and will not recant anything
since it is neither safe nor right to go
against conscience.
A month later,
Luther was declared a heretic and
his arrest was demanded. However,
he managed to escape to Saxony,
which was under the rule of Prince
Elector Friedrich, their visa Fredrick,
the wise some among the upper classes
also felt that it was well timed to reform
the church in some manner.
As I have mentioned in many
other parts of this documentary,
the will of the emperor did
not necessarily supersede
that of the local German
rulers and whether or not Luther's works.
We're effectively Ben and
each area depended on how
the local rulers felt about
them.
Carl,
the fifth's wars with France and the
Ottomans for the more distracted him thus
giving Luther necessary
time while in hiding,
Luther translated the Bible
into German upon completion.
The recently invented printing press
allowed this Bible to be spread across
Germany at a pace
greater than ever before.
The lower classes in Germany found
inspiration and Luther many did not fully
understand the ecclesiastical arguments,
but the peasants did feel as well that
their masters had been abusing them.
Echoing much of what Luther
had stated in his reformation,
this transformed into the German peasants'
war in 1524 where both peasants and
disadvantage and middle classmen and
nobles fought against the nobility of the
swabbing league.
Though massive in number,
the poorly equipped and undisciplined
peasantry. We're overwhelmed by this swab.
Ian Leaks forces more than a hundred
thousand of them were killed and it's
conflict and they managed to achieve
little Luther from whom many of the
peasants drew inspiration initially
condemned the revolt and even later stated
that the peasants should
be killed like mad dogs.
In 1529 it was ordered that the Lutherans
and others separatist groups and their
heresy at the Diet of spare.
These separatists prince's protested if
this order giving them the name of their
branch of Christianity Protestantism,
a unifying name for the non Catholic and
nonorthodox branches of Christianity.
Maybe the label depends on
which Christian group you ask,
but more on that in a future video does
the emphasis on individuals interpreting
the Bible for themselves led to many
subdivisions of Protestantism across the
continent,
Lutheranism and a baptism Calvinism
and many more as time passed,
a divide between Europe would emerge
in the 16th century. By this time,
the eastern church had already split
from the west and to the Greek Orthodox
church affecting these areas here.
Much of the north including Britain,
Scandinavia,
and northern Germany would convert to
Protestantism with the exception of most
of Ireland.
Much of the south along with Poland,
France and southern Germany
would remain Catholic.
Though there are today substantial
nonreligious populations in Europe and a
quickly growing Islamic population.
This generalized religious map of 16th
century Europe is very similar to the
current one.
The division found in Germany is largely
ode to the division of the nation
itself.
In this time with the hopes for resolution
between Catholics and Protestants
waning the Protestants to be Schmall
call Dick League to defend themselves.
By the 1514 Kaiser,
Karl was able to turn his attention back
to the religious situation in Germany.
Tension was in now rising
many territories in Germany.
We're now Protestant and part of the
Schmalkaldic league including sex and eat
in Brandenburg for unembarrassed
conversion included
Hohenzollern master of the
Teutonic order outbreak breakfast first
and 1525 his territory was cut off from
Brandenburg and the other holdings aligns
geographically and politically anti
now styled himself Duke of Prussia
ruling the territory referred to as East
Prussia. East Prussia was not a part
of the holy Roman Empire at this time.
It was more of a fee for Poland as Martin
Luther died in 1546 the two sides were
preparing for war,
which would erupt into these small
call Dick wars later in July.
These conflicts would eventually come
to a close in 1555 with a piece of Alex
Berg and an overall Protestant victory.
The main takeaway of this piece was an
agreement phrased as quiz or Ego Aus
Religio Latin for who's realm is religion.
The prince was to choose the
religion of his territory,
either Lutheran or Catholic
and his subjects were
expected to convert or leave,
which they were freely allowed
to do without repercussion.
This was a major victory for the
nobility over the emperor is yet another
successful challenge to his authority.
It may seem relative to
the age fair and agreeable,
but Catholics and Protestants would not
live happily ever after tension would
build into even greater conflicts
that would ravage Europe. Two degrees,
never before seen following a troubled
and turbulent rural Carla fifth abdicated
from power and 1558 dividing his extensive
Habsburg domains between multiple
EHRs. The Holy Roman Empire going to
fare done on to the first fair to non was
followed by Rudolph the second and 1576
Rudolph was a strange individual who
preferred his private hobbies to the
management of his responsibilities.
Often remaining neutral and conflict
between Protestants and Catholics and many
of the affairs of his day in
general simply to avoid them.
The Bohemian Hussites saw
this as an opportunity to
demand greater rights and to
recognition which Rudolph
granted in the letter of Majesty.
During this time conflict it seemed very
realistic and the German nobility were
busy taking sides.
Both Protestant Union and Catholic week
reformed in 1608 and o nine trouble soon
emerged in Bohemia.
Once again,
the emperor moth lacked a male heir and
so rule was likely to fall to his cousin.
Upon his death though the emperor was as
you know in elected and not necessarily
hereditary position, the Habsburgs would
undoubtedly retain control over it,
resorting to essentially a bribery to
hold onto it for the next few centuries.
Matsyasana. His cousin fair to
[inaudible] was an ardent Catholic,
which concern that the Bohemians fair to
non became king of Bohemia in 1617 when
fair to non intended to revoke the
letter of Majesty has representatives and
Prague were seized by Protestants and
d fenestrated meaning thrown out the
window cause he representatives did
actually somehow survive leading to
immediate propaganda on both sides.
Catholics claiming that they
had been saved by angels,
Protestants that they had fallen in
manure. As revolts began in Bohemia,
this would lead to the outbreak slowly
of what is remembered as the 30 years'
war from 1618 to 1648 involving many of
the major powers of Europe though not
all at once in one drawn out conflict.
In fact,
it can be rather confusing as some has
changed sides and the other war was
started for religious reasons.
The two sides were not split perfectly
between Protestants and Catholics.
Matiaz died in 1618 ferritin on the
second to became emperor. Soon thereafter,
soon Bohemia rose up leading to civil war
and the first of four phases of the 30
years' war.
He promptly named Bohemian Phase in 1620
Protestants and Habsburgs met at the
battle of white mountain
near Prague itself,
resulting in a decisive Catholic victory.
This would effectively end if the
Bohemian revolt and the Habsburgs began to
convert the Bohemians to
Catholicism and following this,
which is why the hussite
religion did not last to to stay.
This could have ended here
as a local revolt. However,
it had brought the concerns of
foreign powers on the table.
The Holy Roman emperor had been acting
especially autocratic this threatened to
the Protestants of Germany and to
Europe in general. Furthermore,
a more powerful United holy Roman Empire
under a leader who could reverse it's
complicated structure was a threat to
the European balance of power. Denmark,
Norway,
a Protestant nation under King Christian,
a fourth who is also the Duke of
Holstine within the holy Roman Empire,
intervened in 1525 by invading and
assisting Protestant rebels beginning the
Danish phase of the war,
the Danish were reinforced by English
and Scottish trips with French funding.
The last part is noticeably ironic
as France was a Catholic nation.
Then led even by a cardinal
funding Protestant rebels
allied to their arch enemy
England.
The essential reason for this was that
the war was evolving to be more about
politics and religion,
friends with simply surrounded by
Habsburgs in Germany and Spain. The Danes,
however, were repelled back into Denmark
by these skill to General Al [inaudible]
Valentine Denmark surrendered in 1629
leading to another Catholic victory in
1630 however,
Sweden intervened again with French
funding under renowned King Gustavus,
Adolphus Sweden.
Shared concerns of Protestant doesn't
being threatened in their own backyard and
of growing Habsburg power.
Sweden was initially greatly successful
against the empire winning victories
such as it brightened Feld,
volunteers,
dine and Adolphus met at the battle of
Ledson in 1632 the Swedes would want
again, but Adolphus would
die leading a cavalry charge.
Volun Stein accused,
though never confirmed of treason
was assassinated the following year.
The Swedish phase of the war ended
in 1635 with the piece of Prague,
those Sweden and France
where it is satisfied.
Sweden continue the war against the
empire and France joined in to lead the
fight personally.
The French phase was the longest and
most violent phase of the war during the
French phase,
fared and on the second died,
and was succeeded by fair to nominate
third and 1637 who viewed the war now as
being draining and desired piece France,
Fatah,
and against the empire and Spain for
the next decade with a mix of results in
1648 the war would end with the infamous
piece of best Follia and this peace
treaty, a number of important
agreements were made,
which would shape the future of Europe,
Switzerland, and the Netherlands,
both formally a part of
the holy Roman Empire.
They'll practically independence
for centuries became
fully independent nations.
France became the dominant continental
power and claim the border region of all
sauce.
Many of the religious conflicts between
Protestants and Catholics were settled
and coexistence among the main branches
was somewhat accepted in Germany,
at least officially. While there was
no true victor of the 30 years' war,
Germany lost the most. Most
of the fighting, as I said,
had taken place within the empire.
8 million people,
soldiers and civilians alike died and
the fighting or an associated feminines
and diseases.
The great majority were imperial subjects.
Germany lost nearly a
third of its population,
including half of its male population.
Hopes of uniting the holy Roman Empire
into what it had once been lost.
After centuries of decline
and the centralization,
this war would strike the greatest
blow to the holy Roman Empire.
It was not destroyed,
but the princess had gained significant
autonomy and freedom from the central
government.
The Habsburgs of Austria would not
successfully research power over them,
though Austria would remain a power in
its own right and had come out of this
war still rather powerful.
It was this holy Roman Empire,
which a century later famous French
radical tier would remark was not holy nor
Roman, nor an empire. As we've
seen throughout his history.
At one point or another, it did have a
respectable claim to each of these titles.
However,
now it was religiously divided
and certainly not wholly
the days of ruling of a
Rome where history and that
was very much not an empire.
More so a loose confederation of hundreds.
In fact,
thousands technically of microstates with
some larger states along with Austria,
one state which had fared
better than the others.
Despite heavy losses and destruction from
the war. It was Brandenburg, Prussia,
which had come out of the
war with territorial gains
under Friedrich Ville home.
The great elector.
As time went on and the holy Roman
empire faded into a relevancy,
Austria and Prussia would rise
to fill the void left in Germany.
Brandenburg Prussia in 1648 was
a disconnected nation ruling.
Other disconnected lands in a map
which is classically holy Roman.
The main territory of Brandenburg was a
poor and resource lacking land and the
military prior to this
point had been feeble.
Much of this was now changing under Duke
Friedrich Wilhelm, the grid elector,
who was consolidating power,
expanding his army and seeking
ways to grow the state's economy.
Even establishing a small colony in
Africa known as he brung and Burger Gold
Coast Prussia was not the only major
state consolidating power. However,
Bavaria and Saxony,
we're also major local players.
Austria simultaneously,
the most powerful of all begin to center
power and its Habsburg territories
within and also outside
of the holy Roman Empire,
these nations at the center of the
continent and therefore it's drama.
We're not left alone to do this.
And peace.
A series of conflicts broke out and
the half century or so following the 30
years of war and the latter
half of the 17th century,
much of the attention
of all Europe frankly,
was on the French King Louis
the 14th throughout his reign,
the Germans would be involved in the
Franco Dutch war, the nine years war,
and the war of Spanish Succession.
Austria furthermore was still on the
boundary of the Ottoman Empire and this
time period,
uh,
Turks were effectively at their zenith
in 1672 the Franco Dutch war began,
which soon evolved into a continental
conflict. The empire under Leopold,
the first and Prussia for
pitted up against France
and Sweden with Brandenburg,
Prussia and Sweden's conflict being
referred to separately as these skinny and
more Prussia was actually
able to repel the Swedish,
which earned it a great deal
of prestige and recognition.
In 1683 the great Turkish war again,
and the infamous battle of Vienna soon
followed on September 12th of that year
when the Turks besieged the city,
the capital of Habsburg, Austria,
and by extension the
imperial capital as well.
Allied forces from across the holy
Roman Empire as well as Hungarians and
importantly Polish came to Vienna is
eight the battle ended with a victory for
the allies and the largest cavalry charge
and history around 20,000 were killed
or captured during the battle itself.
The Holy Roman Empire had been spared
from Turkish rule and the Austrians would
now push into Turkish territory taking
back much of Hungary in Prussia in 1688
Friedrich Ville helm was
succeeded by his son, Friedrich.
The third is Duke and 1701 the war of
Spanish succession broke out with friends
taking on the Habsburgs and
it's English and Dutch allies.
Much of the empire sided with the
Austrian House Berg's. However,
Bavaria seeking the curb,
Austrian power temporarily
cited with the French pressure,
provided the Habsburgs with troops in
exchange for a favor rather than being
freed or to third Duke of Prussia.
He was soon to be styled.
Friedrich the first king in the pressure
since Prussia, unlike Brandenburg,
was never a part of the empire.
Leopold did not contest this much,
though it did anger Poland as the king
of Poland who still control of the much
of the general territory of Prussia,
still claimed the title King of Prussia,
hence the phrase king in
Prussia for Friedrich.
Despite the war favoring
the grant alliance,
the war of Spanish succession ended more
or less in a draw in 1714 as England
and the other allies backed out when the
war over succession to Spain's thrown
began. Emperor Leopold intended
his son Carl, to be King of Spain.
Leopold died in 1705 and his son
and heir Yosef died in 1711 thus,
the imperial throne went to that Carl
becoming Carl to sixth as he would have
been both kings of Spain and the empire,
a threatening prospect. Louise candidate,
his grandson,
Phillipe,
became king of Spain but had to
renounce his claim to the French throne.
Meanwhile,
and Prussia King Fredrick Ville home,
the first had succeeded his father
and 1713 Friedrich Ville helm.
The first would come to be known as the
sole dot and Cuny. The soldier came.
He would continue and expand on the
work of his predecessor is in growing
pressures. Military,
despite its small size,
Brandenburg Prussia was slowly becoming
one of the most powerful states in
Europe because of this
emphasis on the military.
The Sparta of the North Friedrich Ville
home would devote much of his finances
and attention to the military,
even selling off the colony in
Africa to the Dutch and Benning,
a number of luxuries and
recreational activities.
He himself lived a very
disciplined and frugal life.
Despite the power he would come to wield,
the soldier king would
not act aggressively,
only defensively going
to war only if necessary.
Fresher was quite simply vulnerable,
surrounded by larger powers and
his job was to prudently defendant.
Unfortunately in his eyes,
one of his biggest disappointments
and concerns was his own son and heir.
Friedrich Friedrich lack the interest
in the military and state craft,
which is father's so greatly emphasized,
being much more interested
in the arts and learning.
Fridich was accordingly,
often humiliated and abused by his father.
At one point in his life and 1730 he
and a counterpart Han's Herrmann von
Encarta attempted to
flee to England butts.
They were captured and von Cata was
executed for treason with Friedrich and
being forced to watch and may of 1740
Friedrich [inaudible] died and his son
Frederick the second became king and
Prussia. Despite his father's concerns,
Friedrich would not end up a failure.
Rather his skill as a leader would
earn him. The title Friedrich there.
Grossa Frederick the great
as Friedrichs rain began,
another monarchs was ending.
Holy Roman Emperor Carl.
The six was dying without a male heir
and had previously in his reign tried to
ensure the rule of his daughter over
all the Habsburg domains, left unbroken.
His daughter Maria Theresa would become
arch duchess of Austria in 1740 but as a
male position her husband frons the
first would be holy Roman emperor.
Nevertheless, Maria Theresa held
the true power of the empire,
yet it was contested and would
lead to war France, Spain, Bavaria,
Saxony and other German and a non German
powers would oppose the Austrians and
they're British,
Russian and Dutch and hen Avarian allies,
but above all the arch duchess,
his arch enemy was to be Friedrich and
Prussia and December of 1740 as winter
was setting in Friedrich to the Austrian
surprise would make the first move by
invading Silesia to the south and fixing
one of the richest provinces and the
Habsburgs,
the main and the winning important battles
such as Malevich and Hogan freed bear
in 1745 and a peace treaty
between Austria and Prussia.
This conquest was recognized by the
Austrians, a major blow to them.
Yet in 1748 when the whole
Austrian wharfs et session ended,
Maria Theresa emerged with
her reign having been secured
and recognized at a sys
of victory for Prussia,
a mix of results for the Kaiser reading.
This would not be the end of the rivalry
between Austria and Prussia and the
rains of both Friedrich and Maria Theresa.
We're only just beginning.
There was for now a brief period of
peace during which freedom is free to
explore his other refined
interests and speak with guests.
One of whom was the French writer,
Voltaire from Whom Friedrich was
further educated in philosophy,
full tear would say of his kingdom
that while some states have an army,
the Prussian army has a state and with
say of his palace that it was Sparta in
the morning but Athens in the afternoon.
Usually I have to think of these witty
statements but Voltaire did it for me so
thanks Voltaire in 1754 the
seven years war of again,
which would last for nine years.
The conflict originally had begun in
the Americas where it is better known as
the French and Indian war.
The much of the rest of Europe would
only be involved for seven years.
Hence the name confusion. The conflict
was very much the world war of its age.
Being one of the first major
intercontinental conflicts
waged from the Americas
to India,
Prussia and Austria would play major
roles in this conflict as they switched
allies from the prior war with France
and now supporting Austria and Joris is
second king of Britain aligning
himself with Friedrich,
his nephew surrounded and
knowing Austria had its ion.
So Louisiana Friedrich moved
first invading Saxony in
1756 he would then invade
Bohemia but was repelled the Austrians
and French then moved into slightly Zia,
but Friedrich repelled them despite being
heavily outnumbered at the battle of
Rossbach and the battle of lighten each
of them highlighting his genius as a
commander,
Frederick found only mild relief and
these victories he was facing an alliance
of Austria,
France,
Russia and Sweden with only some German
states and Britain as its allies.
Pressure had to fight tooth and nail
and Friedrichs mental health suffered
considerably.
Friedrich likely suffered from mental
illness throughout much of his life.
He wrote occasionally of suicide
and carried poison around with them.
At one point.
He did nearly die in battle,
though his life was spared as his snuffbox
deflected a bullet as pressure verge
towards the feet.
In 1762 queen eulas a of Russia died
and was succeeded by Peter to third.
Peter was German and origin
and was somewhat of a fan
of Prussia and Friedrich.
He soon switched sides and began
attacking Austria. Furthermore,
France was seeing to feed to Britain
across the world and was withdrawing from
the Prussian focus.
It was the miracle of the
House of Brandenburg and
led to pressure the four to
stalemate with Austria giving up
Saxony, but retaining. So Louisiana,
the war ended in 1763 pressures and
Australia's borders remained essentially
similar.
A great victory for Friedrich,
though a disappointment
for the Kaiser Marine.
In 1772 the next move was
made this time in Poland.
Poland was in a state of
decline and Friedrich saw an
opportunity to unite is to
territories. That year. He
arranged with Austria and Russia,
the partition of Poland,
where pieces of Poland,
where each taken by the three powers
Friedrich who hated the Polish,
justified this as a civilizing mission.
Now controlling all of Prussia Frederick
styled himself king of Prussia rather
than merely in in 1765 Maria Theresa's
husband had died and their son Yosef the
second to begin joint
rule with his mother.
She was devastated by her husband's death
and remained in mourning for the rest
of her life. She died 15 years
later in 1780 upon her death,
Friedrich more Inter passing and wrote
that he was her opponent but to never her
enemy and the past.
He did call her the arch whore of Austria,
but whatever. We'll go
with it. Free to come.
Self died in his arm chair on August 17th,
1786 building on the
work of his predecessors,
he had turned Prussia a military power
which could rival any other power on the
continent and has set the stage
for the future of Germany itself.
Though there was still yet change to come.
The rivalry between pressure and Austria
was certainly not over and the fate of
the German people lay in the
hands of these two empires.
Frederick had never envisioned a United
Germany truth be told he was more
similar to the other princes of the day.
I'll be a much more
ambitious and efficient,
but the train of events that would
create one had been set in motion.
The German language spoken today by a
little under a hundred million people is
the official language of Germany,
Austria and leaf inch dine,
one of the official languages of Belgium,
Luxembourg and Switzerland and a regional
or minority language in other parts of
Europe,
South America and even Africa.
Its roots lie in ancient times and that
gradually expanded and diversified over
the centuries creating many dialects
which was sometimes almost unintelligible
and two other Germans sitting alongside
other languages in the empire like check
Dutch and Italian.
This continued until the renaissance era,
a time when many nations we're seeking
to standardize their languages.
Perhaps it doesn't seem like a major
issue if a divided empire has divided
languages, but many individuals
who did business across borders,
like merchants and Holy Roman
emperors saw a benefit in uniformity.
Luther would be key to the German language
is standardization with is widespread
German Bible. It was not by accident
that his Bible appeal to commoners.
Luther went out of his way
to use vocabulary and grammar
that was regular among
common folk and this laid the foundation
for the uniform development of the
language. However, the other regional
dialects did not all disappear.
Take these examples of Varian and all
the Monish compared to standard modern
German, both still spoken and very
much alive though to a lesser extent.
Some German dialects still around today
are very similar to standard German.
Others like these to find themselves on
the border of a dialect and a separate
language, a bit like English and
Scots. So maybe even more distinct.
You may have noticed that German has
what looks like some strange markings or
accents more correctly.
UHMM louts to explain these
just in the K to sound change.
So that margin becomes may Chinn,
which means girl Sam would,
his maiden Boza is Busia many
evil tour is actually tour,
which has the same root as and means door.
What about the fancy looking B?
It's actually not a B.
It's called an s set and represents under
a number of circumstances to ss like
in the word poison,
meaning Prussia.
I actually took German in high school
and then did some self study later.
My German is nowhere near
as good as my French,
but I'd say I'm at least
familiar with the basics. Anyway,
I'd like to think my German teachers
for today's language segment,
Friedrich Ville home.
The second became king of Prussia in 1786
much of his reign was spent focused on
events which would break out in France
three years later, the French revolution,
the French people rose up against
King Louis the 16th and his wife,
Marie Antoinette. Not yet. At this
point in tending to create the republic,
it would become the situation was still
concerning to all European monarchs,
including German ones. If the people
could challenge the monarch of France,
it could happen anywhere.
Furthermore,
Emperor Yosef the second looked on the
situation with more personal concern as
Marie Antoinette was his sister in
1791 the declaration of [inaudible] was
issued declaring mutual Austrian and
Prussian support for Louis the 16th return
to power in 1792 at led to the war of the
first coalition where the Germans were
joined by other powers that as Britain
that year frons the second became holy
Roman emperor.
The coalition forces closed in on France
each seeking to restore a Louis 16 to
the throne and take a piece
of France for themselves,
but the revolutionaries proved
fully able to defend themselves.
In January of 1793 Louis the 16th
was executed later that year.
His wife followed him to the gaiety.
The war continued until 1797 with a
French victory and occupation of western
Germany. While this was occurring,
pressure was distracted by other affairs,
namely the second and
third partitions of Poland,
where Polish territory was
completely divided between Prussia,
Austria and Russia,
and the nation itself ceased to exist
in 1797 the war of the second coalition
broke out, which saw a Russia
enter, but not pressure.
It would last until 1801 with the
same poor results for the allies.
Furthermore,
a young General Napoleon Bonaparte had
to become first console of France in 1799
in a coup d'etat, bringing an end to
the chaos of the French revolution.
But a greater challenge for the Germans
is military genius was already shown at
a number of battles against
Austria and Italy in 1803 however,
war was back on yet again. Austria was
enthusiastically involved, but again,
not Prussia King Friedrich Ville home.
The third,
his intention was to enjoy a neutrality
as Europe tore itself apart. So his wife,
Louisa, was becoming increasingly
supportive of joining the coalition.
Napoleon's attention was eventually on
pushing east and the own campaign in
October of 1805 the Austrian army was
crushed is 60,000 men were captured.
Whereas the Polian took only 2000 losses.
In November,
Napoleon took Vienna itself,
and on the summer second that combined
Austrian and Russian armies were again a
steroid at the famous
battle of Austerlitz,
forcing Austria to surrender following
this surrender cause or fronds.
The second made the bold move to dissolve
the holy Roman empire and abdicate
from the position of Emperor,
the empire seen by Napoleon as an
archaic and inefficient organization.
Long overdue for reform was transformed
into a French satellite state,
known as the Ryan booned or
the Confederation of the Rhine.
Around the same time,
however,
Emperor Franz did change his Austrian
title from Archduke of Austria to Emperor
of Austria.
One might think that the biggest losers
here would have been these smaller
German states. On the contrary. Some
of them, such as Bavaria in Gutenberg,
had actually sided with Napoleon and
not only got Austria off their backs,
but with the empire dissolved,
we're able to absorb many
of the neighboring patches
of microstates and start
calling themselves kings.
There. Power had grown overall,
but the confederation of the Rhine was
still a loose union of about 35 semi
independent states.
Now under a more powerful emperor,
the days of principalities,
the size of cities,
we're coming to a close
except for leakage dine,
which remains the living
remnant of the empire today,
more on that country in
a future video of them.
It was now clear to the Prussians that
they had remained neutral for too long
and a few months later they
declared war on Napoleon,
but the military prowess of Friedrich
the great was not present and his
successors and the French defeated the
Prussians heavily at the battles of Yana
and our Stott and eventually took Perlin.
The following year,
a peace treaty was signed,
which included pressures,
loss of land to the other German states,
and the new Duchy of Poland.
By 1813 however, the tables had
finally turned on the Polian,
but disasters of the Iberian campaign in
Spain and his failed invasion of Russia
enticed the allies including Austria
and Prussia to challenge him once more.
Napoleon was defeated at the battle of
Leipzig, but a sys of coalition victory,
which would encourage the
Ryan Boone to break apart.
And four napoleons German
satellites states to now
switch sides and opposed him.
By 1814 the coalition had taken Paris.
Napoleon was defeated and exiled.
Famously,
he would escape this exile and 1815
and returned to take power once again,
but he was defeated again by Britain,
Prussia,
and other German forces at
Waterloo and exiled once more.
Most Germans then and today would consider
Napoleon a historic adversary with
the contribution he made to
the restructuring of Germany
should not be ignored.
At the Congress of Vienna from 1814 to
1815 overseen by Austrian Cummins von
Metronik. The European powers
met to effectively redraw Europe.
The Confederation of the Ryan was not
replaced with a revival of the holy Roman
Empire, but with the German
confederation or the Deutsche of wound,
which combine the features of both the
holy Roman Empire and the Confederation
of the Rhine. It was a little more like
the old empire and its ineffectiveness.
It included parts of but not
all of Austria and Prussia
and the president of the
confederation was the Austrian emperor,
but it only involved around 39 states
and followed many of Napoleon's
organizational reforms.
Yet the German confederation could not
really be called much more of a country
then you old empire.
It was more like a diplomatic assembly
than an actual congress and that even
included the king of Denmark as Duke of
Holstine and King of Britain as the king
of Pan over.
The intention of the main power is was
to remodel Europe based off the old order
wants to pull the and had fallen. Though
with some important territorial changes,
Russia would gain.
Poland,
Prussia would gain a large amount
of land in western Germany.
The congress of Vienna had
a profound impact on Europe.
Perhaps one of the most peaceful ages of
Europe's history followed as from 1815
to 1914 nearly a hundred years,
not many major military conflicts between
the great European powers erupted.
Though there were still
some important ones,
despite some clamor for reform
and internal tensions externally,
these German borders here basically
remained the same until the 1860s yet
tension was building so there was
still no Germany as we know it today.
Nationalism reform and a new philosophy
was spreading across the continent,
which helps encourage the notion of German
unity and challenge the views of the
age. Austria was a traditional
overseer of the German nations,
but Prussia was becoming a serious
challenger, adding to the issue.
As German reformers faced censorship
and oppression and many Germans faced a
general overpopulation.
Many of them decided to emigrate to new
countries such as the United States,
Canada,
and South America.
The immigrants brought their culture in
lifestyles with them introducing to the
world and new foods like the hamburger
and strange holiday traditions such as
decorating what they called a
Christmas tree. In some areas,
especially in South America, they're
language is still spoken. However,
in the u s where a German Americans are
the number one most common ethnic group
as 14.4% of the population,
the language largely disappeared
during the simulation.
By 1848 discontent became full blown
revolution across not only Germany,
but many nations of Europe.
The communist manifesto was
not by coincidence published
in Germany that year.
Political tension was exacerbated by
feminines economic hardships and other
nationalistic separatists movements
such as in Hungary. Initially,
these movements oversaw successful reforms
and even the beginning of what looked
like a German nation as the Frankfurt
National Assembly formed in May of that
year. What exactly this German
nation should look like. However,
was the first topic of debate,
some favor to gross Deutschland,
meaning large Germany favoring
unification of all Germany with Austria,
others favorite Kleine Deutschland,
small Germany,
x including Austria and it's many
troublesome non German domains.
The nationalists therefore either way
look to Prussia to lead the way to the
creation of this germination,
but King Fredrick Phil how and
the fourth would let them down.
He refused the of what would be Germany
and by 1849 the conservative factions
were winning again and the revolution
including the Frankfort parliament
dispersed their idea of a Germany would
remain theoretical for some decades.
Friedrich Wilhelm was not interested in
the political limitations imposed by the
revolutionaries nor in a war
with Austria over the issue.
But he was not completely averse to
the notion of a United Germany overall
tension was already a building the twin,
the two powers and temporarily it seemed
as though war would erupt in 1850s but
it was averted or more
correctly postponed.
And the 1860s with tension of her power
and the Prussian government between the
king and the new parliament known
as the long tog a bright and active
conservative politician named Otto von
Bismarck was called upon to help resolve
the disputes in 1862 he was made minister,
president of Prussia,
essentially second only to the king,
the well educated in a skilled diplomat.
Bismarck famously stated that Germany
will be forged by iron and blood.
Two years later,
his statement was challenged as Denmark
attempted to annex a territory of
Chesapeake Holstine, sparking war
with both Prussia and Austria,
which the German allies won.
The conquered territory was divided
between Prussia and Austria,
but as you can see,
reaching the region was somewhat awkward
for Austria and the administration over.
It was a subject of contention
between the two powers.
It would eventually become an
excuse for war. Between the two.
In June of 1866 he Ostrow Prussian war
broke out a conflict for which Bismarck
was prepared already ensuring the
new nation of Italy as an ally.
A number of German states joined Prussia,
but Austria was joined by
the more major German states.
The war would last for only seven
weeks with a decisive Prussian victory.
Decided at the battle of Cuny greats.
Following this war,
the German confederation was dissolved
and replaced with the Prussian north
German confederation.
The tables had turned and now Prussia
was seemingly the dominant German nation.
From this moment forward,
Germany and Austria would be
destined to different paths. However,
southern Germany still
remained independent largely
because of internal and
external IEE.
French concerns over full German
unification in 1870 amid rising tensions,
war will be declared between France
and Prussia remembered as the Franco
Prussian war. Thanks to clever
maneuvering and propaganda.
France was viewed as the aggressor
and much of southern Germany feeling
threatened. Allied with the north, which
is precisely what Bismarck intended.
This war would also be short
lasting only six months.
Ending in January of 1871 the French
commanders made a number of egregious
errors resulting in a decisive
Prussian victory of great importance.
Slowly the German states still outside
of the confederation move towards
unification with the rest of Germany.
The last to do so being Bavaria,
that same year the north of
German confederation became
the German Empire under
Kaiser Wilhelm,
the first Chancellor Bismarck and they
right stock a parliament modeled after
the imperial diets and
thus a nation was born.
This nation, however, born from rapid
change, had yet much more change to endure
in 1888 to Ville home. The first was
succeeded by his 29 year old grandson.
They'll Helms Second Ville home.
The second was impulsive, excitable,
and reckless,
possibly suffering from what some
historians believe resembles a personality
disorder.
He stood in stark contrast to Bismarck
and the two quickie got off on the wrong
foot in a time when the relative peace
following the Napoleonic wars was
studying to end as tension was building
between the European powers Villa home,
the second to dismiss
to Bismarck from office.
A decade later in 1897 Bismarck made two
famous statements to Ville home while
visiting him for the last time.
He warned him that in
just a matter of 20 years,
a great war would come if
nothing was done to stop,
it sparked by some damned foolish thing.
And the Balkans as he put it.
Bismarck died a year later at the age
of 83 16 years before he would be proven
correct.
It is eerie how accurate Bismarck was,
but was he psychic or was he a competent
statesman who saw what Kaiser Wilhelm
did not see despite what lay ahead.
For the time being,
Kaiser Wilhelm ruled over
a booming nation. Germany
became a center for Science,
technology, industry, commerce, and
culture. The late to the colonialism game,
it established a number of colonies
in Africa and Southeast Asia.
In the areas of modern day, Papa, New
Guinea, Cameroon, Namibia, and Tanzania.
Germany would also begin a military
buildup which concerned France, Russia,
and Britain. In particular, the triple
alliance of Germany, Austria, Hungary,
and Italy had been formed in the 1880s
and response in 1907 the triple entente
of Britain,
France and Russia had been formed on June
28th of 1914 the dominoes set in place
came falling down.
We're all the war one began archduke
Franz fed and on of Austria was
assassinated by a Serbian
nationalists and response.
Austria invaded Serbia,
the complex string of alliances as
soon came into effect and by August,
Germany and Austria, Hungary, the
central powers, we're at war with Russia,
France, Britain, Serbia to Belgium
and Japan, the allied powers.
Within that year,
the Ottomans would join the central
powers and the year after Italy joined the
allied side.
Despite pass alliances with Germany,
blame for who exactly started the war
remains a topic of debate. However,
it is very evident that all the major
powers were readily prepared for it.
Germany attempted first to invade France
or Belgium and which forced Belgium to
defend itself.
Though it had wanted to remain neutral,
which encouraged British involvement.
Germany surrounded by enemies wanted to
achieve victory as quickly as possible,
though fighting on two fronts, things
initially were going well for Germany,
but at the first battle of the Marne,
they were prevented from
reaching Paris very quickly.
The violence continued territorially.
It stagnated as both sides
dug into defensive positions
across the entire border
leading to the infamous trench warfare.
Germany's colonies in Asia,
poorly prepared for war quickly fell to
Japan and British forces from Australia
and New Zealand.
However,
and the African colonies war raged on
a war that was supposed to be over by
Christmas with a Glorious Durban victory
was now clearly going to drag on into
1915 Germany was strained not
only by fighting on two fronts,
but also being the driving force of the
central powers. Neither Austria, Hungary,
nor the Ottomans were the
empires they used to be,
and Austria in particular with spending
against the Russia and even Serbia and
would soon be stagnating with Italy,
Kaiser Ville Helm was reduced to
being the shadow Kaiser sitting on the
sidelines as his military effectively
took control of the nation.
Gradually the war shifted focus.
Originally the commanders on accustomed
to this new style of warfare.
We're seeking great decisive
battles in quick movements.
In 1915 and 16 it became clear that
that was not how the war was going to be
fought and that instead it became a war
of attrition where each side fight each
other and battles and offensive that
would cost hundreds of thousands and
gradually millions of lives in
attempts to deplete the enemy's men.
And restores is faster with
new devastating technology
such as machine guns,
tanks, submarines, and poison
gas. Halfway through the war,
neither side had yet a clear advantage,
but Germany knew deep down that if it
were a game of who could supply the most
men in resources,
the allies would slowly when knowing this,
both sides gradually
became more aggressive.
Germany breathe a sigh of relief when
Russia exited the war following the
communist revolution in 1917 but it was
a little comfort as over the course of
1916 and 17 how to deal with new enemies.
Most notably,
the United States.
America had tried to remain neutral
throughout the course of the war,
but it had been provoked by German
attacks on some of its ships and a secret
proposal to Mexico to
become a German ally.
If America did enter the war
in Germany's defense, however,
America was clearly leaning towards the
side and indirectly assisting the allies,
the Germans,
new fresh American reinforcements could
finally tip the balance in favor of the
allies.
And that is essentially exactly what
happened in 1918 the allies initiated one
final push against Germany. And though
the central powers fought fiercely.
By November 11th the war was over.
Germany had to surrender despite the
fact that the war lasted only for years.
It was essentially the most destructive
conflict and human history. Up to that.
Estimates vary, but perhaps around
18 million people were killed.
With the subsequent treaty of Versailles
in June of 1919 the Austrian and
Ottoman Empire is we're
completely dissolved and
broken up into multiple other
states, Germany to would have to
make serious concessions. Firstly,
it's overseas colonies were
annexed by Britain and France.
It's mainland territory was divided
into new nations or given to France.
The army was drastically reduced in size.
It accepted responsibility for the war
and was expected to pay reparations for
the damage it had caused.
The German empire was over.
Kaiser Wilhelm had already abdicated.
Germany was now set to become a republic.
The Weimar Republic,
Germany was humiliated and broken by as
the feet and the peace terms forced upon
it to Delta,
yet another major blow to the nation.
The hard shifts the nation
would soon be facing and shame,
it felt would lead to an eventual
backlash and unleash yet another major
conflict on the world that no
one could have predicted. Well,
actually numerous people predicted it,
but either way it was coming
as one might expect.
The years immediately following
the end of the war for Germany,
we're a chaotic and
turbulent various factions,
including notably multiple
socialist factions,
attempted to use the chaos as an
opportunity to seize power in Bavaria.
A socialist republic was even temporarily
proclaimed in April of 1919 but was
disestablished in May, an event
among others, socialists Nomans,
which concerned the more moderate
German people among the Bavarians who
witnessed this firsthand was an Austrian
who had served in the German army,
adult Hitler to add fuel to the
antisemitism in Europe. At the time,
many activists such as a Rosa Luxemburg
and the Bavarian Socialists states
leader,
Oregon Levina were Jewish.
The German economy slowly took a hit
in the 1920s as inflation became worse,
as the government printed more
money to pay for its debts,
the inflation reached levels of outright
absurdity far right and left wing
groups attempted to
capitalize on the crisis.
One such right wing party was he nuts.
Announced Socialistic Disha Deutscher,
our batch apartheid in English,
abbreviated as the Nazi party under
the Afa mentioned at all. Hitler,
Hitler's spoke of a Germany controlled
by and ruined by a Jewish elite end of a
Germany,
which had been unfairly abused by the
allies of the first world war is national
socialist ideology he promised would
reinvigorate Germany and restore its
dignity and honor despite attempts
to prevent his rise to power.
On January 30th,
1933 Hitler became in German chancellor.
Upon his rise to office,
Hitler immediately set about consolidating
power and silencing the multitude of
political parties in Germany.
At the time he began building up his army
and breaking many of the agreements of
the precise treaty, partially in
secret, partially right in the open.
By march of 1938 Austria was
annexed by Germany. By September,
the Sudeten land of the Czech Republic
was annexed. The international community,
or in other words,
Britain and France were very reluctant
to start another war and thus allowed
Germany to NXTs ethnically German areas.
Heather then decided to invade
the rest of the Czech Republic.
Little was done in response,
but la only gave Hitler precious time.
When Germany invaded Poland on
September 1st in 1939 however,
Britain and France were forced to
declare war Hitler using his uplifts.
Craig tactics rolled right through Poland
and a period known as the phony war,
followed as attempts to resolve the
issues diplomatically were made.
Diplomatic resolution did not come in.
Germany merely reaffirmed its goals
and alliances with Japan and Italy who
shared similar goals.
1940 will be marked by a series of
unprecedented victories for the Germans,
defeating multiple European nations
within months or even hours.
The rapid unexpected fall of France
in June of 1940 inspire the Germans,
but the British remained resilient.
Vowing to never surrender.
German plans to invade Britain were upheld
by the invasion of the Soviet Union.
Coined Operation Barbarosa occurred the
year after in June of 1941 the initial
invasion once it's planned until the
winter when the German forces unprepared
for a long conflict over the winter began
to stagnate and the Russians actually
somewhat started to repel
them that winter as well.
Japan declared war on America and Heather
joined them despite now provoking two
major powers.
German military successes continued
into 1942 it is during 1941 or so when
Hitler gain control on the eastern front.
That is racial designs
came further into play.
Drawing on accounts as far back as Rome
of the blonde haired blue eyed gear
money.
Hitler believed that the dramatic peoples
where the most pure and superior of
the area and race,
he viewed other races with contempt
and endeavor to remove many of them to
create layman's around or living
space for the German people,
millions of homosexuals, Gypsies, the
Disabled Slavs that Jehovah's Witnesses,
Africans, and most infamously, the
Jews were all targets of what does.
Remember it as the Holocaust forced
into labor camps or eventually killed by
fall of 1943 the borders of the axis
powers were starting to attract.
Russia was reclaiming territory
and the allies were invading Italy.
The following year on June 6th
as Russia continued its advanced,
the allied forces from a multitude of
nations landed on the beaches of Normandy
in France.
By December of 1944 the Third Reich was
clearly starting to be reduced to its
original borders. That month hit. They're
launched his last major offensive,
which resulted in the battle of the bulge.
By January it had failed and that was
soon clear that Germany would not win the
war. On April 30th as the Soviets
took Berlin, Hitler committed suicide.
On May 8th Germany officially
surrendered to the allied.
It had been the most destructive conflict
and world history and remains so to
this day with 60 million people or around
3% of the world's population having
been killed, including 7 million
Germans following the war,
German territory was
divided among the allies.
Poland was permanently given many of the
areas of the historic Prussian Empire.
The militarism of Prussia was seen as the
driving force of the German militarism,
which had caused the
world wars and in fact,
Hitler had idolized Friedrich the grade.
Thus,
it was seen as wise to
stamp out its image.
Russia occupied the east of the nation
as well as territory near the city of
Koenigsberg. The French occupied the
south west and these SAR protectorate,
the British, the northwest,
and the Americans.
The South Berlin was likewise split
between the four allies with the Soviets
controlling the east.
Germany had once again been defeated
this time with much harsher punishments.
It would not be so quickly reunited. The
relationship between the western powers,
notably the United States and the
Soviet Union was very tenuous.
Even during the war Germany,
we'd become a main battleground and the
immediate conflict which followed the
Cold War from 1947 to 1991 gradually,
the multiple occupied zones
became two separate countries.
In 1949 after a period
known as the Nazi vacation,
the Federal Republic of Germany or
western Germany and the German Democratic
Republic or east to Germany were formed
after less than a century of unification,
Germany was once again
divided as relations between
west and east became more
and more tense.
Germany found itself in the middle.
The Soviets and East Germans erected a
wall in 1961 in Berlin throughout the
sixties and seventies the height of the
Cold War, a number of incidents occurred,
which nearly resulted in war in Germany.
By the eighties however,
tensions began to relax.
By 1989 the East German government
had begun to falter on November 9th,
1989 the Berlin Wall was opened officially
partially by a miscommunication,
allowing Germans to cross much
more freely between borders.
On October 3rd,
1990 after 40 years of the vision,
Germany became a unified and
independent nation. Once again,
largely in thanks to men such as
Helmut Kohl reunified Germany's first
chancellor,
October 3rd is still celebrated as the
togther Deutsch and Einheit the day of
German unity.
Today,
Germany remains a major nation in multiple
areas and carries considerable weight
and the decisions that affect a
Europe, the west, and the planet.
We have thus covered about
3000 years of German history,
the story of Germany's ancestors,
as for the next 3000 years.
That depends upon the decisions made
by the German people living today.
I hope you enjoy this documentary.
If you did,
I'd recommend checking out some of my
other work and subscribing to see more
videos like this in the future to
help with the cost of production.
Fire of learning does
take donations on Patrion.
The link to which you can find in
a description Donka for watching.